i really value stories told by writers
who are able to
to go out into life and experience it
and come back and help make some sense
of it
can you explain why a writer must
understand their own story before they
can essentially understand any character
stories that they may invent
my wife cassie
took this idea of defining moments and
pushed it a step further by saying
this isn't just about
concocting
moments for our characters it really
begins with us
understanding our own story so she
when she teaches young writers will say
again and again before you can
understand
your character story you have to
understand your own story
so if we're going to understand the
dynamic of the way moments can reshape
us and transform us
the best place for us to look is in our
own experience
we have a front row seat to our own
invisible inner emotional life and so
we've got to
be willing to
uh to draw on that
but before i can draw on my own
life my own defining moments i have to
actually
locate them
so
while i might not want to crack open
an old dvd
i have to crack open my own history if
i'm going to tap into
the emotional
riches
that lie there for
all of us because we all
have
uh in the words of author frederick
beekner wonderful and terrible things
that have happened to us all
and so
the idea is that we would look at those
things
so as an example
a kind of moment that might define us
would be
the moment a dream was born
and so somebody who's pursuing acting
directing writing
often
that
that's based around a dream
and so the question that i would ask is
when was that dream born
can you locate
the moment of birth for that dream
and sometimes there is a moment
and sometimes things
emerge
so gradually
that we can't locate a moment we've got
glaciers that creep imperceptibly but
then we also have glaciers when they
reach the sea
that in
dramatic fashion will cave a glacier in
a moment
what we're interested in as dramatists
are those dramatic moments
so the tectonic plates of the earth
move milli meter by millimeter over the
decades centuries millennia
it's not that interesting to watch
but there is an instant when they
rupture
and we have an earthquake those are the
dramatic moments
so there are times when
changes happen in us
by these gradual processes
and
that we may not call those defining
moments but there are these cataclysmic
seismic moments of change
that
make great stories but also really help
to define
how that change happened
so you might look back and say let me
locate
what is that moment where i became
obsessed with screenwriting
when is that moment when i had to make
movies or had to make television
we also think about
characters and we think about people as
being
broken damaged
and
so we can look back and say
not only
i know i've limped like this for a long
time but we can ask the question when
did i get that limp
what was the moment of injury
and if
we understand that moment we get a great
story but we also understand maybe if
this is how it happened with me
this may be how it happens with my
characters as well
and
i don't only want to tell bleak stories
about people being injured and damaged i
i am interested in a credible kind of
hope and so i'm also interested in
asking
like was there ever a time where i grew
was there ever a time where i healed
that i overcame a fear
what did that moment look like
and if i understand that in myself
then i'm in a position
to
portray that in a character
and
that will be lifelike
and emotionally authentic because it's
rooted in something that i've actually
experienced so i think that that is the
vulnerability and the cost that comes
with being a storyteller
is that we have to be willing to
do that dive into
our our own emotional story
and
be willing
disguised or not to to bring those
stories forward um and it's tough
you go into a
meeting at a studio and you sit with a
producer or an executive and you pitch
this character arc and you say i think
this is where
this character's damage comes from and
what you're really telling is a story
from your own history
you don't necessarily tell them that
but if that gets shot down
well that's a little bit vulnerable
that's sort of a rejection of you and
your pain and your past
but
there's also the possibility that the
producer will say oh that's right
something like that happened to me
and suddenly you've got a common
point of reference for this character
and certainly when you are
communicating with a big audience
if those moments actually make it to the
screen
you've created the possibility of
connection with
thousands of people millions of people
in a way that they really relate to and
when we connect at that deep level with
characters
we care
we're invested emotionally in what
happens to them that's what gets us
sitting on the edge of our seats
it's not just that we've got
spectacular visual effects and
characters zipping across the screen if
i don't care about those characters
i'm bored
with even the most spectacular visual
effects
if i identify with a character and
deeply care what happens to them
then the tiniest
movement
either toward or away from danger
i i feel viscerally so i think that's
the value for writers in connecting with
their own defining moments so that they
can then
enrich their work with
the insights they gain
some of our comments i've seen people
mention that they didn't
have anything too tragic to write about
but they were still able to
portray that in their stories and they
said you know i didn't come from a
dysfunctional family and i had a great
childhood but
there's this myth that i have to be
damaged in order to be a great writer do
you ever see people that are just
too far on the spectrum either
everything is just tragic and what was
me and there was no growth and then
others that
now everything was like disneyland
i do encounter writers a lot who when i
ask them
to find
moments that have shaped them
struggle with that and often discount
their life experience as boring or low
stakes
and i had i had one student who was not
a 20 year old
who came to me i knew that she was a
pediatrician
and
um but she came to me with this
problem of nothing's happened to me
and i said well
so your career is you work in the
hospital with
desperately ill children and their
families
i think you have experienced
deeply emotional high stakes things
and she thought about it and she said
well
i guess it's true i am a 50 year old
woman and no man has ever loved me
and i said
then you
you have lots of stories you have
deep emotion
but
i think we have to honor
our own life experience and not
dismiss it as unimportant
now somebody who only
like who wallows in tragedy and damage
i think that we
i think that we want more than stories
of chaos
i think we do want stories that help us
make sense
of
lives that often feel like chaos to us
at least
while we're in the middle of
the story
and so
i really value stories told by writers
who are able to
to go out into life and experience it
and come back and help make some sense
of it even if it is
not the neat disney package
[Music]
i think of
joel and ethan cohen's no country for
old men
and uh
there's not a ton of hope in that movie
uh there's a line of
uh i think it's
uh tommy lee jones who says you can't
stop what's coming referring to
just the sort of growing evil that he
was seeing in the world as a
sheriff or marshall in texas
that's kind of hopeless you can't stop
what's coming
toward the end of the film
tommy lee jones character tells a story
of riding out
into the wilderness i think it's a dream
he has
he's on a horse riding out into the
wilderness and his dad has ridden out
ahead of him and has lit a campfire
and he says in his dream he's riding
along and he catches sight
far off in the distance of that campfire
and that's it that's all the hope that
there is in that movie
but it's enough
to say
somewhere out there in the darkness
uh there is warmth and there is light
keep writing
that can be
for somebody who
experiences
a lot of adversity
that can ring true to them in a way that
a disney movie
never will
that can be credible hope and so
i value that kind of storytelling and i
would push a
a writer who
only sees bleakness
to look harder in the same way that i
would encourage
a writer who only sees
happiness
to be more honest with themselves and
own up to
whatever the pain
and disappointments have been that's
hard to do
i think sometimes that can only happen
after some therapy and after some years
have passed and we can dare
to
crack open the package and look inside
but i think the audience craves that
kind of
that kind of honesty
you're trying to remember back to patch
adams it's been a little bit since i've
seen it but speaking of a pediatrician
i think at some point it's revealed why
the character wants to
you know bring joy to these children and
sort of this clown-esque type
yeah i think there's some
tragic past which keeps it from
being
a silly movie it's not a silly movie
and
it is
it's the pain and the darkness that
balances out
the
the fact that he wears a clown nose to
clinic um he he knows something about
pain and of course
robin williams
knew a lot about pain was well
acquainted with that and
that undergirded
both his dramatic acting and as comic
acting